Chrissa from twitter ass you guys speak
about a lot of value a lot about value
as being an overarching thing that
determines what you keep or appreciate
how do you determine this value since it
seems so subjective it is subjective do
you use a formula I use the quadratic
formula right cuz you're so awesome
what about objects that have sporadic /
intermittent purposes think about
hobbies that you have yeah I mean it's
Chris that adding value is you know does
it serve a purpose or bring you joy and
it is subjective and hopefully it's both
that's the best things yeah yeah that's
true but that's why that that question
is so important is because you know
asking yourself what adds value that
allows you to look at it subjectively
mm-hmm and it allows you to determine
for yourself what truly does serve a
purpose or brings you joy it is it is a
very I don't want to say an ambiguous
thing I guess subjective that's probably
the best just descriptor of absolutely
its objective and yeah and it's
subjective from your Ferns current self
versus your past self versus versus your
future self that subjectiveness changes
over time and and so notice that it
becomes fluid in a way Matthew from
Facebook I was gonna say too sometimes
there's something something that does
add value though like think about
Facebook right leg you you can get about
Mariah and I were having this
conversation yesterday you can get about
10% value from Facebook
she's like laughing at these like cat
videos oh look how cute this is and you
know she's like oh I didn't realize this
event was going on but then there's 90%
of you know she had a friend who like
posted this picture this before after
picture I've lost 20 pounds I was just
like a picture of their face and and
mean light and there was no difference
in the pictures it was just like this
attempt of like please give me attention
you know and it's so it's like some
things that do add value they also they
also can take away from you away so
determining you know what the net with
the net is like that's kind of important
we call that imaginary value when you
when you list out your values by the way
if you if you haven't listed out your
values go to minimal wellness.com slash
values
Rebecca has a whole like values
checklist and how you can set up your
own values and you can determine what
are your imaginary values or really what
are the obstacles because Facebook then
at that point becomes an obstacle for
you it's an imaginary value
you